for you it might be in reverse if you're
youtube first and you think youtube
first
what if you started a show what if you
started a video podcast
and i'm not asking you to rush into this
i'm asking you to make a game plan
i'm asking you to calculate it how much
time would i need to carve out what
could i do what would my system be
how would i pull that off what are the
strategies that are working on youtube
right now what's changed on the youtube
platform and how can you apply these
changes to grow your views and your
subscribers
on youtube well in this episode we're
going to be diving into that
and so much more and i want to welcome
you to the think
media podcast my name is heather torres
the host of this podcast
and we're here to help you grow your
influence on youtube and then
use that influence to grow a high impact
and a high profit
youtube channel and i am getting so
excited because we are getting
so close to our annual conference grow
with video live it's happening in august
of 2021 so you might be listening to
this episode in
a few weeks or a few days before the
conference and i want to encourage you
to grab
your tickets they're going fast this is
a virtual conference you can
uh take from that you can attend from
anywhere
in the world i'll tell you more about
that after today's episode
but let's get into what's working on
youtube right now and a little bit of a
taste
of what we're going to be teaching at
this year's conference
[Music]
our passion here at the think media
podcast is to always be
in the trenches like youtube scientists
like guinea pigs
testing trying things testing theories
posting videos doing experiments and
then passing along the things that are
working for us
to you we try to do that on this podcast
in our videos
and that's also the deeper purpose of
our courses and our events
is really pass along tested not just
hypothesis and thesises but things that
have actually been
tested on our channels and on our
students channels
and sharing those with you and i've got
seven things
that we've been up to there's really
kind of a playbook of probably about 10
things we've been up to over the last
year
but we're going to touch on a couple of
those and these are actually going to be
some of the topics we're going a lot
deeper on
at our upcoming virtual event called
grow with video live but i wanted to
just give you
some of the things that we're paying
attention to and the first one is
youtube shorts have you started posting
youtube shorts
yet you know youtube shorts is one of
the most probably revolutionary
updates to the youtube platform in a
long time of course
in competition with tick tock and reels
youtube wanted to step into the short
form
content game and views have grown to
over a billion views a month rather
quickly which is very significant
rivaling some of those competitor
platforms
and so youtube is taking this very
seriously if you haven't created a
youtube short yet
it's basically just vertical content
that's under 60 seconds
and if you update your youtube app you
should see the ability to actually
create a shorts with a shorts creator
right there on your mobile app this
allows you to record
multiple clips add them together put
words in there put music in there
and really the reason we're paying
attention to youtube shorts is because
frankly
they're getting a lot of views if you do
them right especially in certain niches
one of our video ranking academy
students plants and lucia
has been on the platform for a little
over a year she's doing great i believe
coming up on 40
000 or more subscribers and she's put
out some great videos and some of her
most viewed videos
maybe have 50 60 70 80 000 views but in
a short time she's had a couple shorts
get
30 000 views 40 000 views 50 000 views
and in a very short time this is the
power of
shorts now she does plants she's talking
about how to water air plants and
different things
and so there's certain niches whether
that's cooking or tutorial or
entertainment or
definitely deeper diy type of content
and it's been a very powerful strategy
for her that listen
it leads to awareness when maybe 60 000
people
55 000 of which aren't even your
subscribers are discovering you for the
first time
this is new subscribers this is getting
your content in front of new people
and it could be a major way to grow and
it's not just for like entertainment or
diy or plant or cooking channels you
know chris doe
from the future does educating education
really for uh freelancers videographers
people like that
and he's had some shorts his top viewed
video on his channel
is a youtube short so it's definitely
something i want to encourage you to
experiment with and i can't wait to dive
into deeper strategies at our upcoming
event related to youtube's shorts that
we've been testing on our channel and
some of the case studies from our
students
the second one is just money making
strategies
i would assume that you're here on this
podcast
because you either want to make a
part-time or full-time income with
youtube or you want to get
additional revenue in your business
driving more leads driving more sales
or creating additional income streams
you know i kind of think about uh roger
wakefield and we've had him
on some of our events and some of our
challenges sharing his story
um he's been a uh we've been able to
influence
some of his success he's been able to
just crush it in the plumbing niche
and he had a million dollar plumbing
business but now that he's doing youtube
he's getting brand deals to the tune of
six figures
that's additional revenue from plumbing
brands
that want to sponsor his content he's
getting a lot of ad revenue because the
views are going up
when he goes live he can get super chat
revenue and different things
and so there's always ways to innovate
your money making strategies and this is
going to be one of the deepest topics
that we're talking about
at growth video live and a couple ideas
for you though
is long-form content why
because in long-form content you can add
multiple ad spots
now you might be uncomfortable maybe you
didn't know you could do that
but once your channel's monetized you
can go in and you can have what's called
mid rolls not just like a skippable ad
at the beginning but there could be
skippable ads in the middle
and for really long videos um there
could be multiple ad spots
now there's different opinions on this
and you can always do what you want but
what's
interesting is i've just kind of learned
that man it's maybe one percent of
people or less that are like oh that was
kind of annoying or
you know uh i don't really want to
interrupt people's day
listen you need money for the mission i
don't know about you
but i pay for hulu like and i watch
shows on hulu and i'm still getting ads
i pay not to see ads
and yet i still get ads on hulu i i
haven't quite
decoded the matrix here but like they're
just still there and i'm like
i guess this is how things are you know
like and
at the end of the day i'm over it about
the after the first ad i'm like this is
sort of annoying and then i'm like i
guess we're back to
traditional tv or what because the way
content is monetized in its rawest form
is with ad spots and if you're putting
out great content i think about one of
heather taurus's videos
on how to make a video with your
smartphone it's 45 minutes
she talks about how to shoot a video how
to make a thumbnail how to edit the
video and then how to upload it all from
your phone
and so in those segments in between
those segments
are ad spots like it's kind of a natural
break
so this one video has generated
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars
by having multiple ad spots on long-form
content we're going to talk more about
that but also
secondly under this is higher cpm topics
you know you're probably not going to
drift from your main channel topic if
your niches
or topic of your channel is you know
something specific
crafts diy sewing you know but
there are higher cpm niches usually
personal finance
real estate e-commerce software software
as a service
but i think about my friend ryan pineda
who talks a lot about real estate that's
a pretty high cpm
talks about turo supercars and
that's an app where you can rent super
he talks about these different things
but he talked about amazon ecommerce
stores in just a couple videos and i was
just
hanging at his office we were looking at
the cpm's on his videos
the cpm was over a hundred dollars on
those episodes where he talked about
drop shipping in amazon e-commerce
stores the typical cpm
which is the amount of money you earn
for a thousand monetized views on
youtube
is two to five dollars when he was
talking about the amazon ecommerce stuff
over a hundred dollar cpms
when you have this kind of knowledge
you're able to
make some videos that could be related
to your niche that are potentially in
higher cp related to higher cpm topics
that can really scale your youtube
ad revenue so that's kind of a newer
money making strategy to be thinking
about
of course if you start a live show
there's super chat and super stickers
channel memberships ben from keto camp
or our friend emily baker
is has channel memberships with people
subscribing for exclusive content
on their channel and then there's all
kinds of off-platform strategies
and there's new places like buy me a
coffee
and kofi and different places where you
can kind of like patreon
find ways to monetize your audience in
creative ways so you have
money for the mission so you can
continue to serve people and so
those are some things to consider some
new youtube features some things you
can't ignore
in relation to making money but number
three start a live show
i think one of the best things you could
do over this next year
is start a live show now it might scare
you if you're not comfortable yet
don't worry about it but maybe make it
an ambition
that in the next two months you start
getting ready you start practicing in
the next six months
you start a live show you know during
the pandemic right in the heart of 2020
everybody was locked down i think media
all of our travel got
canceled we were worried because we had
a really hard month going into the
pandemic where we were negative
30 000 on our p l and so
one of our things that we did during
that season was we did not
shrink and go back on defense we leaned
in and we went on on offense
and we thought man we got to keep
connecting with people we got to keep
encouraging people we got gotta keep
teaching we just gotta lean in
and we started two live shows and those
two live shows happen
on we actually started three live shows
we started a monthly
think media q a episode or training
episode and
omar does that predominantly right now
on our think media channel
but we also started the coffee with
kennel show which if you've ever seen it
you might think like this is the thing
it started during a really hard season
it started when we wanted to give up and
shrink back
but we leaned in and heather started the
youtube made simple show and those shows
stream predominantly on our think media
podcast youtube channel
but they have been an incredible
blessing because they've kept us
connecting with people they've kept us
putting something on the calendar
that'll stretch us and challenge us
they've kept us uh leaning in to sharpen
our skills and learn more so we can
share more
they've kept us focusing more on our
performance than our applause
they've kept us really leaning in and
this goes to tip number four
they've also helped us repurpose content
because what we do
is we're able to go do a live show and
by the way this is really basic we don't
have any logos yet we've been doing this
thing
over a year we don't have any theme
music like it's just called
the coffee with kennel show like i'm
like hey welcome to the show like i
i don't there's no jingle there's no
graphics by this time there probably
should be
and we want to evolve into that but like
starting a show is just like naming it
claiming it planning your flag and
leaning in and doing it and like you can
evolve it over the years
as you go it's the weekly q a show with
you
it's the five minutes with marley it's
the you know
it's the tip tuesday it's just a show
it's a consistent thing that'll keep
you consistent challenge you and will
have you showing up
regularly for your audience but number
four what we've done
is we've realized that when recording
for
45 minutes 90 minutes sometimes i go two
hours sometimes
and a lot of times i'll bring on guests
and i'll either answer questions
using stream yard one of our favorite
softwares where we can just put the
questions on screen right from the chat
or we share a link that allows people to
join kind of like a zoom call
and then we can do q a right in the show
well that turns out
that if that interaction is valuable
there's a five minute clip a seven
minute clip and eight minute clip
from the live show that gets repurposed
so i can cut that up
i can cut that down and sometimes we use
that on social media or sometimes we
upload that
on think media remember this is
happening on our second channel but you
could even have it happen on your main
channel i was coaching
uh a a bigger influencer recently huge
business but like
newer to youtube and she was just kind
of restreaming to youtube
a lot of two hour episodes and i was
like out of those two hour episodes
you need to be posting the five minute
clip and the eight minute clip and the
ten minute clip from those
that were the highlights the best
moments those are additional uploads
you can make them a little stronger
because you can trim the fluff and if
you stumbled over your words or whatever
and
add a little music or do whatever you
just cut that clip out
it's not unlike if you think about joe
rogan who's exclusively on spotify now
but his clip show remains on youtube
in a day gone by his full length episode
was on a youtube channel and he had the
jre clips channel
and sometimes those clips would amount
to more views than the main episode
because there'd be five clips from a
three hour conversation
so number three start a show number four
repurpose
content and i can't wait to get into
some of our repurposing
strategies and we're gonna be going deep
on this at grow with video live
to talk about the best practices we've
learned the mistakes we've learned
because when you implement this man this
can
2x 3x 10x your channel in a very very
powerful way number five premieres
premieres are cool if you go into your
youtube analytics you can see three
types of videos
you know sometimes our analytics look
different but this is what you should
see
it'll say how many views your
uploads get in the first 24 hours or
seven days how many views
your live streams get and also say how
many views your premieres get you can
also go deeper
and it'll say what is the average view
duration of an upload
versus a live stream versus a premiere a
premiere is simply an upload
that is scheduled ahead of time so that
you essentially like a movie premiere
can do a special red carpet event
where hopefully you're there in the chat
so you can hype up around it say i'm
going to be answering questions during
it i just want to watch it with you
you can get super chats during premieres
you can get
super stickers during premieres which is
a way to monetize and
premieres are ideal for long-form
content like if you upload a longer
video
it's a great idea to premiere it and
that's another feature that's
underutilized by a lot of people number
six
content marathons uh we won't go into
that here but i can't
it's one of the most powerful strategies
we've been using and it's been saving us
a lot of time
at think media and then number seven is
video podcasting and as we land the
plane
i want to encourage you to consider
starting a video podcast now
we are anti-overwhelmed here at think
media we are
team focus here at think media so when i
when i release and or share all these
ideas with you i'm not insinuating that
you need to
frantically react and rush
hastily into any of these what i'm
actually recommending
is that you start to calculate and carve
out a game plan
for leaning into the best strategies for
you
over the next 3 6 9 12 months
you know we had it in our heart to do a
podcast for two years before the podcast
started
and we wanted to build team and systems
or bandwidth and margin before we
started it
but even as a solo creator i think that
video podcasting could be one of the
best strategies you lean into
the reason why is by video podcasting
you are able to lean into youtube just
like we do with the think media podcast
we record the podcast on video therefore
we not just can post them on youtube but
then the audio can go on spotify and
apple and android and all the different
platforms and we use a tool that makes
it pretty easy called buzz sprout
and it just sort of we distribute the
content across platforms
but then we also because we have video
and audio
we cut up clips from the video podcast
and sometimes those become instagram tvs
they become instagram reels little
moments of them
and sometimes even from the video
podcast that's maybe
20 minutes long 30 minutes long 40
minutes long right
uh we end up cutting out a clip
that actually can become a think media
video because our think media podcast
channel is a separate channel
or just a shorter video on the think
media podcast channel
remember leaning into repurposing what
i'm encouraging you to do
is think about maximizing your efforts
and your impact doing one thing and
using it in multiple ways
creating one piece of content and
expanding it across multiple platforms
creating one piece of content and
chopping it up and repurposing it
not in a kind of thrown away haphazard
not add value type of a way but actually
we found
people aren't complaining they're not
like oh that was i saw that in the
podcast
i can't believe i saw that other four
minute some people don't even want to
watch the 30 minute podcast but they
will click on the four minute
highlight of the episode you did or the
interview you did
and there's so many things you could do
with video podcasting you just need zoom
my friend kerry knew off i was on his
leadership podcast and i think he has
nearly a hundred thousand listeners
per episode something crazy he's got
he's helping a lot of leaders
he used to be a pastor now he's really
still helping faith-based organizations
but just leaders in general
love his podcast and he had me on to
talk about youtube and we were on
zoom together and he was recording the
episode and
he told me he goes you know sean i just
like having zoom on because i like
seeing the guest
um i don't use the video i just use the
audio but
that way there's kind of more
interaction as we're talking and and i
said
wait a minute carrie so so you've
recorded video
of every single guest you've had and
it's mainly an interview show where he
interviews leaders and authors and
people teaching leadership
john maxwell and simon cynic and guys
like that
and uh he goes yeah sean my uh i've got
all the zoom
recordings on my computer so
first i had a a long uncomfortable pause
i replied up i said carrie
it is irresponsible of you
to not post those videos
on youtube i'm like even if
you don't title them well put a good
thumbnail on them
and there's no strategy there you're
just
you're on a mission to serve leaders
right yes as many leaders as possible
right
yes and who are these the video files
reaching on your computer
nobody and who could they reach if you
post it on you youtube
somebody carrie you you can already do a
video pie you don't need
and but i get it right and of course
he's a friend so i'm kind of giving him
a hard time but i'm serious i'm like bro
this is
you gotta you gotta start doing this
perfectionism holds us back
you might if you're watching this
episode on youtube you might be like
dude what the heck dude they got a
studio
there you know they got sony cameras
like the audio is good there's sound
panels in the room
listen don't compare your beginning to
somebody else's middle
you can video podcast with very basic
setups
and that's what kerry knew off started
to do and what's crazy
is again his youtube his audio podcast
was crushing
youtube videos they sometimes get 200
views 350 views
450 views but what's interesting
is now we look back in some of those
episodes 5 500 views
12 500 views those could have just been
sitting on his computer
but he leaned in to start leveraging
youtube to turn into his podcast not
just into an audio podcast but into a
video podcast
for you it might be in reverse if you're
youtube first and you think youtube
first
what if you started a show what if you
started a video podcast
and i'm not asking you to rush into this
i'm asking you to make a game plan
i'm asking you to calculate it how much
time would i need to carve out what
could i do
what would my system be how would i pull
that off
and so youtube shorts new money making
strategies start a live show repurpose
content
youtube premieres content marathons
video podcasting these are actually just
a few of some of the things we've really
been leaning into
over the last year at think media and i
want to invite you if you haven't got
your ticket yet for growth video live
2021
get registered growthvideolive.com it's
a two-day virtual event so you don't
have to worry about a plane ticket or a
hotel room you can just make some
popcorn
hang with the family get on the couch
and a virtual pass is good for your
household so maybe
you want to connect with uh maybe you
got a virtual assistant you got a team
you know someone on on your team someone
you want to just
like you can get a ticket and then make
sure to spend
two days with us because we're gonna be
going deeper into these strategies and
other strategies
breaking these down so you can implement
strategically
because you know execution is the game
ideas are a commodity like having good
ideas is one thing
putting those ideas into practice in an
intentional
and strategic way as well is where the
real action is and the entire event
we're going to be sharing case studies
we're gonna be sharing practical
real world examples from every different
niche we're gonna be sharing stories of
people who are just starting that have
had breakout success
starting just months ago people that are
just getting into the youtube game so
it's not just
this is not out of touch youtube
celebrities and gurus you can't relate
with
you're going to be learning from people
that are really doing it just like you
so you can get an edge on youtube you're
going to be learning the best ways to
make money and how to really find
your path because at the end of growth
video live what we want you to leave
with
is not just clarity and we need that we
want you to have clarity on what you
need to do next where you are on your
journey
and what are the next couple moves for
you
when it comes to really building a high
profit and high impact youtube business
you're also gonna have built up your
community
what do i mean relationships we've got
like networking parties
on zoom like we've got like breakouts on
zoom we got like stuff happening where
you'll have a chance to connect with
others
and and small group breakout rooms and
like cool stuff happening
where you can connect with other
creators and forge relationships
even in a virtual world world and then
finally
the last thing you're going to leave
with is a content game plan
like you're going to leave with a game
plan so you can implement the right
strategies so you can crush on youtube
for the next year and
beyond so i really a hope you just
start exploring these and thinking about
how this episode could be applied to
your business but b
if you're ready to really take these
strategies and some of our other
secrets and strategies that we've been
testing at think media get to
growethvideolive.com
because myself on the think media team
cannot wait to hang out with you
virtually in the number one
youtube marketing event for
entrepreneurs uh growwithvideolive.com
that's coming up at the end
of august so that was just a taste
of what we're going to be teaching at
this year's grow with video live
conference we have
so much packed into two days we have
different options for you
general admission vip so many things
happening
one reason that i love this conference
is because it's interactive it's fully
immersive
and we can't wait to see you this year
we are going to be teaching on new
youtube strategies how to make
income off of youtube we're gonna be
interviewing some people who have gotten
to a hundred thousand subscribers on
their journey to that and so
much more so make sure you lock in your
tickets
at growwithvideolive.com and
attend with a friend what i love about
this conference is that
we're gonna be having so many ways that
you can be interacting with content
creators from around the world
and next door next door i don't know do
you live next door to your best friend i
wish i did
so make sure you get your tickets at
growwithvideolive.com and
if you're new to this podcast one of my
favorite things to do on
every single podcast is read your
reviews
it brings me so much joy to be able to
get to read your reviews
and see how this podcast is impacting
your youtube
journey you know on think media our main
channel we go deep into tech and editing
and gear and all the things
that you need to make youtube videos but
here on the podcast
we get to go deeper we get to talk in
more about the mindset and the
psychology around
being a content creator and so i love
this
uh review from becca over on apple
podcast she says
don't miss out on this valuable must
listen
every tuesday morning after i do my
morning bible study i immediately
listened to the think
media podcast well she said think
marketing podcast but we did a little
name change
not you know nothing to worry about
which means it's the second thing i do
every tuesday and that's been my
schedule for almost a year now
a few things to know first if you're
involved in entrepreneurship
online content creation or any
combination of these
related to starting growing or thriving
as a purpose-driven
mission leader you need to listen to
this podcast
not just want but need next the
information shared in the way it is
shared by sean heather
and any and all other members of the
think team
or guests who come on for interviews is
extremely accessible and implementable
implementable that's a fun word
almost immediately after every episode
but
also uniquely valuable becca i wish i
could hug you right now i love this
comment so much because
it really is the heart and mission
behind this podcast thank you so much
for being one of our tuesday ritual
podcast listeners you can hashtag that
on social media
and i'm just grateful that you are a
part of our think media team
or think media community and that you
left
that review for the podcast thank you
thank you thank you if you haven't left
your review yet
you can do that over on apple podcast
rate and review this so that other
people know
how good this podcast is no that's kind
of a brag but really
so that other people can see if this
podcast
is right for them well thank you so much
for being a part of our community
thank you for leaning in thank you for
being a content creator that takes
action one of my favorite things to do
is to see
your videos succeeding and i'm so
grateful that you are a part of our
community
and that you're sharing this out on
social so that i can see
what's up in your neck of the woods
thanks for being a part of what we're
doing here at think and we'll catch you
in the next episode
bye not growing on youtube learn the
newest strategies for getting views and
the best proven ways to make money
at grow with video live a two-day
virtual conference
and you can get your tickets today at
girlwithvideolive.com
you